[музика]
Щиро вітаємо вас все програми фокусі
Європи телекомпанії Deutsche Welle
війна в Україні триває вже майже півроку
і російські атаки не припиняються
тривають постійні артилерійські обстріли
на Сході та півдні України
президент росії Путін має на меті все ж
захопити Донбас
тим часом Україна публічно документує
тяжкі воєнні злочини проти своїх
громадян і водночас нарощує Контрнаступ
сотні тисяч українських воїнів ведуть
запеклу боротьбу з російськими
загарбниками
їхня стійкість здивувало багатьох але
через військову перевагу Росії вони
втратили чимало важливих позицій
відтоді як від західних союзників почали
надходити важке озброєння українська
армія контратакувала в тому числі і на
півдні
їхні перші досягнення на окупованій
Херсонщині показали що ця війна буде
довгою і запеклою
Українські війська глибоко окопалися тут
між миколаєвом та херсоном
посеред південноукраїнських степів вони
Тепер постійно тримають російські
війська на прицілі
відтоді як українська сторона розпочала
Контрнаступ Вікінг як він сам себе
називає разом із товаришами намагається
тиснути на позиції росіян в тому числі
за допомогою артилерії вона не може
зрівнятися по кількості снарядів які
вона може випустити росіянам Зате ми
переважаємо їх поточності по швидкості
оперативності дій там де вони
розгортають цілу батарею і луплять так
як це робили ще їхні діди і в Другій
світовій війні ми працюємо по дві по три
установки швиденько відстрілюємося
знімаємося і міняємо умову позицію
мета відвоювати Херсон велике українське
місто яке зараз під російською окупацією
Анастасія Борисова лише нещодавно втекла
із Херсонської області Зараз вона в
Одесі
благодійні організації зібрали одяг для
новоприбулих
до міста прибуло майже 150 тисяч
біженців
Анастасія прожила в окупації кілька
місяців поки страх не став занадто
сильним
Та ми увидели что в городе как ми
побачили що в місті крім військової
техніки з написом ЗЕД з'явилася також
техніка з написом в
це означає що вони стягують війська з
інших напрямків тобто вони знають що тут
буде величезна бійня і Ми зрозуміли що
не хочемо все це бачити
[музика]
але їх змусив поїхати не лише страх
перед бойовими діями їхні рідне місто
Нова Каховка нагадує місто привид
там Вона майже не виходила на вулицю
коли ти знаходишся Серед російських
військових ти опускаєш Погляд щоб не дай
боже довго не було зорового контакту бо
тоді Вони думають раз Ти довго дивишся
значить щось знаєш Пішли поговоримо І не
факт що ти повернешся так багатьох уже
повисмикували з натовпу і потім їх
шукають до Одеси щодня продовжують
прибувати нові біженці і з окупованих
територій
шлях сюди небезпечний і не тільки через
бойові дії російські блокпости
пропускають лише по кілька автомобілів
[музика]
однак є рятівники які витягують людей
ми зустрічаємося з однією із них
показати її обличчя Ми не можемо
зараз військових більше ніж раніше таке
відчуття що під кожним деревом є
контрольно-пропускний пункти в будинках
ще більше замаскованих снайперів у
Херсоні ми могли раніше вільно
пересуватися на нас ніхто не звертав
уваги але зараз ми більше не наважуємося
ходити в центр міста
Анастасія втекла якраз вчасно її
квартиру обстріляли Невдовзі після її
втечі
знайомі надіслали знімки
тепер вона зі своїми дітьми має звикати
до нормальності адже кожен стукіт у
двері викликає спогади
[оплески]
[музика]
нет Танки
[оплески]
сьогодні на фронті Тихо В окопах обідня
перерва
останніми тижнями українці націлились на
російській лінії постачання
вони постійно знищують російські склади
боєприпасів
відображаються тим що напевно періоди
часу інтенсивність світлолюбських
обстрілів вона трошки падає але росіяни
також перебудовують свою логістику і
роблять висновки із уроків яким дають
фермерси і дальнобійна артилерія кома
отримують партнерів тому на жаль ну
війна не йде Скажімо так в нього ворота
на нашу користь це постійний процес який
міняється
Україна змогла відвоювати деякі села але
наступі де повільно
Вікінг та його товариші не знають
скільки часу їм доведеться ще тут сидіти
а для того щоб проводити Контрнаступ
швидко агресивно активно І дійсно вже
великих масштабах нам знову ж таки треба
ще більше озброєння від партнерів
зокрема без артилерії без артилерії
просто моторна піхоти і ми насправдімося
тож слід чекати і бути обережними навіть
під час прийому їжі наступний напад є
лише питанням часу
Ольга стрельник одна з понад 6 мільйонів
українців які втекли з батьківщини та
зареєструвалися як біженці в нижці
європейських країн вибір Ольги припав на
регіон Галіція на північному заході
Іспанії узбережжя Атлантичного океану
тут обривисте а погода була іноді досить
суворою але Ольга почувається наче вдома
і це багато в чому пов'язано з морем
місцевим жителями та одним дуже
гостинним маленьким містечком
тут неначе вдома в Одесі Атлантичний
океан нагадує Ользі стрільник про її
Батьківщину на Чорному морі Вона разом
зі своєю сім'єю Та майже сотнею інших
людей втекла від війни в Україні сюди на
північ Іспанії
тепер Вони моя сім'я Мені легше в такому
гарному місті з привідними людьми люди в
карінью дуже доброзичливі
каріні оце назва маленького села
іспанського воно означає любов або
прихильність і саме це Ольга та її
колеги пізнають тут цього через кілька
місяців вони вже беруть участь у
традиційному фестивалі сардин
це невелике село Тут можна зустріти всіх
і запитати як справи
[музика]
люди у галісійському каріні допомогли їй
освоїтися і почати все заново
ми приймаємо Тут усіх
Каріною Привітне село і українцям тут
звісно раді їх тут поважають
Хай в єрколорадо мантигас карітасу
місцями допомагає де може а він знає
всіх новоселів села
ми могли познайомитися ще ближче якби
вони володіли мовою Трохи краще але це
власне лише питання часу а діти просто
чудові вони вбирають справді все і дуже
швидко вивчають мову
у каріні у менш ніж 400 мешканців
населення старіє і донедавна
скорочувалося
молоді люди які сюди приїхали є для нас
оновленням
більше людей працездатного віку
це омолоджує нашу громаду
Ольга стрильник та її колеги бачать для
себе хороше професійне майбутнє в
Україні Вони працюють на успішний портал
автозапчастин коли почалася війна вона
та її колеги були в каріні у справах а
збиралися розширюватися і працювати
онлайн також і в Іспанії
люди в галіції допомагають Якщо хтось
хоче заснувати підприємство
ніж у Мадриді чи інших великих містах
Іспанії
ми не просто хочемо залишитися на рік
заробити грошей і знову поїхати Ми
хочемо створити тут велике підприємство
сьогодні вони Вперше у своїх нових
офісах робота є бажаним відволіканням
від війни на батьківщині та страху за
рідних які там залишилися її колезі
магдаліні Шпак це Добре відомо Українка
живе в каріні вже багато років а вона
допомогла переїхати десяткам людей і
Поєднує їх із місцевими жителями
є дуже велика різниця між біженцями та
мігрантами
мігранти залишають свою країну тому що
вони цього хочуть вони планують думають
де хотіли б жити
такої можливості не мають а вони
вирушають ні з чим
після початку війни Ольга стрельник
повернулась до Одеси вона повинна була
забрати на кордоні з Румунією своїх
дітей 16-річного гордія та дев'ятирічну
агату і відвести їх у безпечне місце
Це було жахливо там в черзі було стільки
людей і я так боялася за своїх дітей
її колишній чоловік залишився і мама ще
в Одесі а вони розмовляють по кілька
разів на день
А зараз усі цілком відкрито говорять про
те як живеться і ніхто не каже що все
добре чи нормально
Ти можеш спокійно казати що тобі сумно
тобі чогось бракує або що ти радієш
знайомству з новими людьми зараз багато
чого більше не є формальністю
оскільки усі зрозуміли що кожен день
може бути останнім
після своєї втечі нові мешканці каріні
хочуть щось організувати і село від
цього виграє адже їхнє цифрова
бізнес-одея створює робочі місця а
відновлена ними кав'ярня є місцем
зустрічі де новий старий можуть
продовжувати рости разом
без допомоги ми б не впорались ми
приїхали лише з однією валізою і все
нам потрібно молодь яка має бажання
знову запустити тут економіку
і наповнити школи
кожен виклався як міг і це почесно для
нашого села
А дехто з молодих українців хоче
залишитися в карінію також і після війни
інші хотіли б колись повернутися але
маленька Одеса на півночі Іспанії
назавжди залишиться частиною їхнього
життя кажуть вони
що станеться з країною в якій живуть ці
молоді Північній ірланці вони про
англійські протестанти які вірять що
Північна Ірландія належить Великій
Британії однак багато їхніх
однокласників навпаки є ірландськими
католиками які прагнуть Возз'єднання з
Республікою Ірландію десятилітні
конфлікт з який старше покоління
боролися жорстоко та кривавого зараз у
прикордонному місці кроссмаклен знову
зростає напруженість тепер яку відчуває
і молодь
пісні гарно вивчені
гамільтонс Браун Сільвер бренд добре
підготувався до свого маршу
[музика]
18-річна Люся бінгом виросла тут у сім'ї
протестантів
[музика]
всі в оркестрі протестанти і традиційно
відчувають зв'язок із великою британією
але в цій місцевості вони в меншості
навколо живуть католики так звані
націоналісти і після британського
брекзіду в повітрі знову повисла напруга
суспільство тут розділене
нас оточують націоналісти
ми б ніколи не зайшли в їхні райони
через заворушення в минулому багато
людей тут усе ще зляться один на одного
і здається що ситуація погіршується хоча
ми цього не хочемо
в минулому протестанти відчували що їх
тут переслідують Колись її сім'я була
мішенню католицьких вбивств Іра каже
Люсі тепер вона знову відчуває загрозу
за всяку ціну вона хоче бути частиною
Великої Британії
після браксіту схожа на те що ми станемо
частиною об'єднаної Ірландії
цього ми не хочемо У жодному випадку
Люсі живе Всього за кілька кілометрів
від кордону з Республікою Ірландії але
майже ніколи його не перетинає
кроосман католицьке місто колишня
твердиня Іра молодіжний центр
знаходиться прямо біля колишньої великої
військової бази католицька молодь тут
має зовсім іншу ідентичність вони
постійно перетинають кордон мають сім'ї
в Республіці Ірландія
Я відчуваю себе ірланцем
і не скажу що я британець Я дуже
прив'язаний до Ірландії
[музика]
хоча Північна Ірландія є частиною
Великої Британії Я відчуваю себе
ірланкою адже ми знаходимося на острові
Ірландії
опитування свідчать про можливість
подальшого членства об'єднаної Ірландії
в ЄС
ірландський націоналісти шин фейн
колишній політичне крило Іра вперше
стали найсильнішою партією після
регіональних виборів на початку літа ліс
кімінс є членом регіонального парламенту
коронавіруси брексі та змусили людей
усвідомити переваги які вони отримали
якби були частиною ірландської
республіки це природній процес
і звичайно ми зробимо все можливе щоб це
сталося
однак насильницьке минуле тут досі
пам'ятають за меморіалами загиблим
бійцям доглядають обидві сторони
наголошує що вони змінилися вони вже
давно хочуть досягти своєї мети
об'єднаної Ірландії виключно мирним
шляхом
ми всі хочемо вжити в Мирному та
благополучному суспільстві у всіх нас -
Це спільне
тим хто боїться змін Ми кажемо
Приєднуйтесь до дискусій Ми хочемо
робити це разом Щоб позбавити всіх
страху
але щоб залучити всіх протестантів
відданих ангелів зокрема Люсі
знадобиться багато такту і витримки
Я сподіваюся що мені ніколи не
доведеться побачити об'єднану Ірландію
поки я живу Я хочу бути частиною Великої
Британії
[музика]
Гамільтон з баун Сільвер бенд більше
думає так як Люсі але водночас вони
відчувають що все може скластися інакше
на сьогодні не завтра але в недалекому
майбутньому
Павло в Лондоні тим часом великий шок
через те що у перший політичній хвилі
Північної Ірландії схожий змінилися і
партія яка не виступає за те що Україна
залишилася у Великій Британії отримала
більшість голосів у національній
асамблеї в белфасті
час льодовиків схоже закінчується лід
європейських Альпах тане Все швидше
зміна клімату та глобальне потепління
спричиняють руйнування льодовиків А в
деяких випадках навіть дуже різке як тут
у липні в мармеладі на півночі Італії
тут загинуло 11 людей
таких експерти як Флоріан газ побоюються
що великі частини альт можуть повністю
втратити свій лід цього за кілька
десятиліть зазначити різких змін
подібних до тих що спостерігається
льодовиковому гепаштфернер в Австрії
одне місто в Італії також може сильно
постраждати від зміни клімату та
підвищення рівня моря Венеція місто
Лагуна його перетинають численні
мальовничі канали які знову вирують
життям якщо трохи придивитися до гондол
водних таксі та човні Ви помітите що
здебільшого ними керують чоловіки однак
незабаром це може змінитися завдяки цій
жінці Марті каніно вона робить усе
Можливо що більше жінок взяли в руки
кермо
цей краєвид відкривається лише із човна
кожен хто хоче вільно переставатися
венецією повинен вміти кермувати
повертає в інший бік далі
рухайся далі не бійся
урок кермування для Валентини зі своєю
вчителькою Мартою вона вчиться сьогодні
причалювати
цей човен дуже маневрений оскільки має
пласке дно тому дуже важливо щоб
Валентина могла його контролювати і
добре ним керувати А вона повинна
вирішувати коли потрібна більша а коли
менша швидкість і як рухатися з точністю
до міліметра
нещодавно Валентина повернулася до
Венеції після 10 років перебування за
кордоном з любов'ю до міста до Лагуни і
тому що їй бракувало цього краєвиду
жителям міста дозволено пересуватися
каналами на невеликих човнах але вона не
почувалася при цьому впевненою тому
вирішила піти на заняття
мене особливо лякав двигун на жаль це
дуже чоловічий світ
а Венеція після пандемії туристи
повернулися
маленькі вулички і канали заповнені
щоб проїхати по великому каналу потрібна
велика сміливість досі Тут їздять
здебільшого чоловіки тому Мар така Ніно
заснувала товариство за допомогою якого
вона хоче залучити жінок Венеції до
кермування човнами ідея виникла в неї у
2020 році
світ за тих Венеція порожня Венеція якої
ще не бачили навіть старі венеціанці
тоді вона застрягла вдома з дворічним
сином
дозвіл був лише на найважливіше
Венеція місто яке нічого іншого крім
натовпу людей не знає паралізоване і
громадський рух народних автобусах
суворо обмежений
Марті пощастило А вона має свій човен
Вона водить його ще з дитинства поїздки
на човні забезпечують обом свіже повітря
а згодом Вона відкрила сторінку у
Фейсбуці бо хоче дати свободу яку вона
має завдяки власному човну і іншим
жінкам
Раптом ми з'ясували що залишались
переважно жінки та матері з колясками
дітьми їх просто не брали бо кількість в
апоретто була обмежена
я моментально зрозуміла бажання багатьох
жінок які зателефонували відразу ж після
публікування сайту
і відтоді дзвінки не припиняються
її ідея переросла в товариство яке
розмістилося прямо посеред корабельні
девіз Повний вперед спочатку були криві
погляди і зарозумілі а висловлювання Але
разом зі своєю подругою луїзою вона це
витримала вони дають жінкам уроки
кермування та проводять теоретичні
заняття товариство само себе забезпечує
тобто воно фінансується за рахунок
пожертв уроків кермування та членських
внесків той хто телефонує має негайно
отримати їхню допомогу
якщо найменшими намагаємось одразу
сказати так це так само коли жінка хоче
підстригтися я знаю що комусь це може
здатися нісенітницею але значення має
саме цей день саме ця мить неможливо
чекати два тижні це потреба в змінах яка
вимагає негайної реакції
своїми уроками кермування вона хоче
також забезпечити майбутні Венеції щоб
жителі які тут ще є тут і залишалися
поїздка по малих каналах останній
привілеї який у них лишився Свобода
незалежність у місті яке за словами
Марти стало пустелею для місцевих
повнотуристів крамниць і пропозицій які
не мають для них жодної цінності
Сьогодні сусілія вперше виїжджає на
гранд-канал найкрасивіший але водночас і
найнебезпечніший канал Венеції
повернулися туристи водні автобуси і
таксі але в них трохи менше місця ніж
раніше і тепер доводиться ділитись також
із жінками
Я сподіваюсь що цей проект
розвиватиметься і далі
чолни які раніше повинні сполучати всі
місця та всіх світиться цього міста
подивись попереду нас гондола таксі
авапорецьці містріальто на тебе
дивляться 100 тисяч очей Усе чудово Не
хвилюйся
Марта та її учениці не збираються
відмовлятися від знову здобутої Свободи
на воді
що ж будь ласка не гальмуйте Повний
вперед
Це була програма фокусі і робить
телекомпанії Deutsche Welle
Дякуємо за ваші інтерес до побачення
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив переклад Володимира та Олесю
Швед режисер Павло Тимченко так читали
Олена потоцька Юлія Лисенко та Олеся
Київ 2022 рік
[музика]